I understand that your wife is pregnant
yes I did nothing I just did well you
did well really okay are you how are you
feeling about this this is a huge life
change yeah it's it's it's great I like
when I get a round of applause for that
because she gets all the attention
usually yeah and yeah we're gonna do a
natural birth early opposed I guess is
supernatural yes yeah yeah the natural
yeah and she yeah so you know and she at
first was like maybe we should do it at
home and I said you know look either way
when you go into labor I will be
checking into a hospital so I I need
doctor I'm I have a lot of anxiety about
this so if you want to come along come
along
so she said fine we'll go to the I just
don't think we need to give birth on a
kitchen table and it's not Jamestown ya
know we've evolved yeah you know doesn't
it be a butter churn in the corner no we
can go to a hospital so she said well
then let's do a midwife we not a doctor
I said okay so we went to go meet this
Midwife and I thought it was gonna be
like a you know a hut in Topanga or
something right and Janis Joplin was
gonna come out with like a good do trust
exercise yeah but but it was a real it's
a real doctor midwives are yes they're
very good midwives yes they're lovely
company and so I I went to Beverly Hills
to meet this Midwife and my wife in
Beverly Hills yeah I love that I know
you think they'd be in nature it just
sounds so salt of the earth I know
now where should I meet you in Beverly
Hills yeah yeah exactly that's that's
what I hide the blacksmith shop
yeah yeah or Tiffany yeah yeah so yeah
so it's like a long haul long Rove you
know examination rooms we went in met
her in the room and then I went to the
bathroom and came back and opened the
door and saw you know legs up in the air
and a doctor look up and she said wrong
room wrong room Oh God everything the
wrong ride was I walked into the wrong
examination room man and I'm bad enough
at facial recognition that bad angle and
where I was at it all looked I was ready
to you know - I saw I saw more that day
than that I can't was yeah did you well
no I didn't ask I didn't recognize her
from that angle whoever was yeah and I
did a terrible mistake to make I know
and and yeah and I'm off to a rocky
start in on the road to fatherhood but
but I got a free preview
[Applause]